the omicron variant continues to cause
real problems you're seeing cases rising
in in hospitals but
it is
obviously milder than the uh the delta
variant and
uh
we're able to proceed in the way that we
are but that's one reason and one reason
only why we're able to do that and
that's because such a huge proportion of
the british public have come forward to
get vaccinated and particularly to get
boosted
and
we've done about 32 and a half maybe
more million booster jabs now and that
is allowing us to to go ahead with new
year in the cautious way that we are
but i cannot stress too much how vital
it is for everybody to get that booster
jab
particularly the 2.4 million people
who've had two jabs but haven't yet had
their boots and they had two jabs more
than uh six or seven months ago so
they're eligible for their booster but
they're not yet coming forward to get it
so i said people come forward and get
your booster it's a fantastic thing to
do it makes a huge amount of difference
to to you it protects you and i'm sorry
to say this
but the overwhelming majority
of people who are currently ending up in
intensive care in our hospitals are
people who are not boosted i i've talked
to doctors who say the numbers are
running up to 90 of people in intensive
care who are not boosted
if you're not vaccinated you're eight
times more likely to get into hospital
altogether so it's a great thing to do
it's very very important get boosted uh
for yourself and and enjoy new year
sensibly and cautiously why have you
acted differently to the other devolved
nations
i think that we've looked at the
uh balance of the of the risks together
we generally concert our strategies
together we see
the
data
showing that yes the case cases are
rising and yes hospitalizations are
arising but what is making a huge
difference
is the
level of
booster resistance the level of
vaccine-induced resistance in the
population
and what we need to do now is really
finish off that work and i've no doubt
at all that by
january the first by by by the new year
everybody in every adult in the country
would have been offered the the slot to
get a booster
they'll be given a slot to get one the
question is are we getting people coming
forward to make to take advantage of
those slots and that's what needs to
happen there's a lot of stuff in the
press about people going over the border
in wales and scotland to come to england
for the new year what do you make of
that i think everybody should enjoy a
new year but in a in a cautious and
sensible way
take a test ventilation uh think about
uh others but above all get a get a
booster what have you seen that they
have not why have you acted differently
we're looking at the we're looking at
the the data and what we're seeing is
that
we've got cases uh
certainly uh going up we've got a lot of
cases of omicron
but on the other hand we can see the
data about the relative
mildness of omicron and what we can also
see is the the very very clear effect
of getting those jabs getting uh those
boosters in particular and that's what's
making a huge difference
according to some of the surveys i've
seen
90 percent
90
of the patients in icu are people who
are not boosted so think about that
think about the risk you're running with
your own health if you fail
to get a booster you've got a question
from itm yes who have you been for the
last 10 days
i've been in i've been
in this country